the North American interpreter natee
conference announced tough new
restrictions on hard liquor in all
fraternities earlier this year it
follows a settlement between the family
of Penn State student Timothy Piazza and
his fraternity where the 19 year old
died during a hazing ritual last year
there's been at least one hazing related
death in the u.s. every year since the
early 1960s Penn State President Eric
Barron tells Jericka Duncan about his
personal mission to prevent future
tragedies it needs to be very clear that
if you engage in behavior that harms
somebody physically or mentally to a
level of of near death or serious
consequences that can't be a misdemeanor
Penn State President Eric Barron says
reforming laws to make hazing a felony
is just one of the causes he's been
fighting for over a year and a half ever
since nineteen year-old engineering
student Timothy Piazza died in a hazing
incident on his watch why have you made
this your mission I never wanted to
happen again that's really why I never
wanted to happen again as part of an
initiation ritual with Beta Theta Pi
Piazza was allegedly forced to consume
18 drinks in 82 minutes he died two days
later in the hospital after sustaining
brain injuries and massive internal
bleeding from dangerous Falls while
intoxicated at the fraternity house it's
hard still hard the pain doesn't really
go away parents Jim and Evelyn Piazza
have formed a unique relationship with
President Barron working together too in
hazing nationwide we thought well we
could either go to battle with him and
the University or we could try to work
with him and in trying to effectuate
change not that we don't have our
differences we do and there are things
that we don't agree on we don't agree on
everything but it's important for us to
work closely with him with the
University to make changes here some of
those changes include a national
database to monitor Greek life like
fraternity GPAs sexual assaults and any
alcohol violations when I'm choosing as
a student or as a parent I can look at
it and say no wait a minute that house
the freshmen have a 1.9 grade point
average do I want to risk my academic
to join that one and some people might
look at the fraternity that Timothy
Piazza was associated with and say well
that fraternity had a stellar record I
think it was the average 3.8 GPA it was
a good it looked very good on the
outside and there are other things here
that have a different type of effect on
behavior we're working with the Piazza
is on an anti-hazing law - Piazza was
our son he was your classmate he
should've been graduating this year
last week Barron invited the Piazza's to
visit Penn State and speak to the heads
of fraternities and sororities we need
to get to the students yeah they're the
ones that you know unfortunately carry
out the crimes right a nurse pulls your
mom forward and tells her to kiss her
baby goodbye I'm sure many of you have
been hazed and probably have haze but
I'm asking today you make a commitment
to yourself that you're not gonna allow
that to happen anymore
what sort of feedback have you gotten
now that you've been across the country
we've gotten really good feedback we've
had young men look us in the eyes burst
into tears give us hugs and just
promised us that it wasn't going to
happen on their watch since 1960 at
least one person has died in a hazing
incident across the United States do you
believe that maybe perhaps this year we
won't see any deaths when it comes to
hazing I hope so I hope we've all been
loud enough and the University says it's
already seeing progress there's a
substantial change in awareness I think
that gives us a lot more strength to
begin to move forward aggressively in
fixing it but we're not done yet
for CBS this morning Jericka Duncan
State College Pennsylvania we should
also point out the Piazza's are still
fighting for justice in court the more
serious charges of involuntary
manslaughter those were recently dropped
charges have been filed dismissed and
recalled against more than 25 of his
former fraternity brothers three
students have pleaded guilty one is now
under arrest but I think the Piazza is
knowing that the court system has been
slow have said we can lobby we can help
make changes in other ways and I so
admire the piastres as you know they've
all been here at the table that and you
know how painful this is for them
nothing is more effective I think than
those parents looking those kids in the
eye and say you guys can stop this it
doesn't have to happen if there was some
way that they could talk to every
fraternity remember tattoo to make that
case it would be so powerful I believe
John it makes a difference